[Music]
Hello dear friends and welcome to I like
to know this program that allows us to
answer your questions those that uh have
sent us. We have really enjoy and
appreciate that question those inquiries
that helps us to understand and for us
to study it ourselves. So we value your
questions and we invite you to send us
and continue to make this program
interesting and relevant. So you can
send your question to TVsv.org.
That is again tvsv.org.
I am in company with pastor Steven
Boore. Pastor, thank you for being with
us in the program and as always a
pleasure to work with you.
>> This is one of my favorite programs
because it forces me to do research.
Thank you. And I I know people
appreciate your input and your studies.
So we want to uh start this program. But
before we start the program, pastor, we
want to ask the Holy Spirit to lead us
into all truth. And we want to pray. So
if you please could lead us into prayer
as we prepare to open this program.
>> Let's pray. Father in heaven, so many
questions in this life and many times
few answers, but you have all of the
answers.
>> Amen. And we do our best, we struggle to
find answers to the questions that uh
people send us. Some involve mysteries
that we will never be able to
understand. But there are many questions
that after research we can find answers
to those questions. So we ask that as we
answer the questions today that your
Holy Spirit will be with us to instruct
us. Give us clear minds, give us clear
words and that our answers might be
satisfactory for the spiritual growth of
those who ask the questions. We pray in
Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. All right, Pastor Bore, what
questions we have for us for us today?
What questions do we have?
>> Okay. All questions that we get are good
questions. Amen. There's no such thing
as a bad question. So don't don't feel
uh intimidated by saying ah you know
that's just not an important question.
We will try to answer this question is
very interesting. Dear pastors
uh just uh doesn't have a name or an
address just full name R. Okay. Dear
pastors may God bless you all. My
question is, do we get the white robes
at conversion?
If it has stains, when when will it be
removed? At death or during the
investigative judgment? When we die, we
have to be wearing the white robe. Is it
the same thing uh that when we have a
white robe, when we die, that our names
will be retained in the book of life?
Many thanks in advance. So in synthesis,
this question has to do with when we
receive the white robe and how. Is it at
conversion? Is it during the
investigative judgment? Or is it when
Jesus comes? Or perhaps is it all three?
>> That's a good question, pastor. And I
think let's start from the beginning.
When do you get the
new garment, if I will? Uh we have
obviously the several passages but I
would pref like to start in John chapter
3 in regards to the work of
when you receive the new garment the
white garment.
uh this this chapter as we know is a
chapter between Nicodemus and Jesus as
they enter into this uh conversation and
Jesus explains to him how is it that you
are to enter or have the right to enter
into the kingdom of life on in the
kingdom of life and and so here it says
there in verse 7
Jesus says do not marvel that I say unto
you you must be born again so
and then it says the wind verse Eight,
the wind blows where it wishes and you
hear the sound of it, but cannot tell
when it comes from and where it goes. So
it's everyone who is born of the spirit.
So in the moment of conversion, you may
not know when that process started, how
exactly the Lord worked in your heart,
but you do know that there's a moment
where you are born again. You're
changed. You are
not longer that individual who was
living a life of sin who enjoys sin who
now has come to Christ receive his
pardon and becomes a new creature. So
that newborn experience is the moment
you receive those white garments. It's
like in the experience of uh or the
revel of the vision that Zachariah had
of Joshua the high priest you know he
was filthy garments the lord said remove
those garments. When you are converted,
you are born of the spirit. And this
experience of baptism is kind of that
symbol of of you being born again. You
are washed from your sins and you are
given that new robe spiritually
speaking. It's a it's a spiritual robe.
It's not physical obviously, but you
have received a spiritual robe where
Jesus covers your sins, your life with
his perfect righteousness, his blood.
That's the garment experience that you
receive. But it's not just that moment
that you keep those you receive those
white garments. Now the process is how
to keep them. And I believe Christ makes
it very clear that we are to keep those
garments, not just receive it once and
be done with them. Mhm.
>> And so in Revelation 3 uh 4 and 5, we
see this message that God Jesus sent to
the church of Sardis and says, "You have
a few names even in Sardis who have not
defiled their garments, and they shall
walk with me in white, for they are
worthy." And he who overcomes shall be
clothed in white garments, and I will
not borrow his name from the book of
life, but I will confess his name before
my father and before his angels. So here
we have this declaration of Jesus that
people are to walk with them with him
with white garments. You are to keep
those garments white by surrendering by
obedience to the Lord by trusting in him
and by depending on Christ.
>> You know I have added uh some
explanations in brackets of this very
passage that you came up with.
>> Yes. Um, and by the way, uh, in this
program, we all do our independent
research. Yeah.
>> And it's amazing how so many times we
come up with the same Bible verses.
>> Amen. For that
>> when we were talking right before the
program, this was one passage that you
said, "I've got that one."
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'm going to add my interpretative
statements.
>> Absolutely.
>> Uh, in here, uh, they're not I'll tell
you when it's not part of scripture, but
it's an explanation.
>> Yes.
>> It says, "God is speaking to the church
of Sardis." Mhm.
>> You have a few names.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh which are going to be examined in the
judgment because the judgment brings
forth names.
>> Yes.
>> And examines the life. So you have a few
names even in Sardis who have not
defiled their garments. That means that
they did not defile their garments while
they were living.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh it's in other words, it's a spiritual
garments in this life. Mhm.
>> It continues, "And they shall, this is
in the future kingdom,
>> walk with me in white, that's literal
white robes,
>> for they are worthy." Now, when were
they uh shown to be worthy? In the
investigative judgment, when their life
was examined.
>> Verse five, he notice it's an individual
thing. Mhm.
>> He who overcomes when in this life
>> shall be future
>> in the kingdom when Jesus comes clothed
with white garments and I will not blot
out his name. This is the investigative
judgment. I will not blot out his name
from the book of life but I will in the
future confess his individual name in
the heavenly judgment before my father
and before his angels. So basically
there's three stages here.
>> We need to keep our garments now.
>> Now
>> uh we need to keep them white.
>> Yes.
>> That's where you find Revelation 16
verse1 15, right?
>> Where Jesus says, "Behold, I'm coming as
a thief. Blessed is he who watches and
keeps his garments."
>> Now it's a process. It's a continuous
thing. Keeps his garments lest he walked
naked and they see his shame. Whenever
the Bible speaks about walking
figuratively, it has to do with your
behavior or your conduct. So once again,
I will not blot out he is that
individual's name from the book of life,
but I will future confess his individual
name that is in the heavenly judgment
before my father and before his angels.
So now keep your spiritual robe and in
the investigative judgment, your case is
investigated to see if you kept your
robe. Mhm.
>> And then uh Jesus will clothe us with
literal white robes when he comes.
>> And pastor that actually helps us
understand uh Revelation 69-11
uh the fifth seal.
>> Uh and I'll read it so that we can you
know because the question maybe
sometimes people can get confused with
this particular passage. It says there,
"When he opened the fifth seal, I saw
under the altar the souls of those who
had been slain for the word of God and
for their testimony which they held. And
they cried with a loud voice, saying,
"How long, O Lord, holy and true, until
you judge and avenge the our blood on
those who dwell on the earth." Then a
white robe was given to each of them.
And it was said to them that they should
rest a little while longer until both
the number of their fellow servants and
their brethren who should be killed as
they were were was completed. So here we
are seeing how these individuals are no
longer alive. They're dead. And the Lord
says because you have overcome, I'm
going to give you I have reserved the
white garments for you. Mhm.
>> Uh literally they will receive the
physical garment, the white garment that
everybody will receive when the Lord is
done with the plan of uh of you know
with the investigation of judgment when
he's coming back to to redeem us. And so
that's when you will receive the
physical experience, but the spiritual
experience happens from the moment
you're converted. And you are to keep
that garment white by surrendering and
walking with the Lord in a daily basis.
And of course the purpose of the
investigated judgment
>> yes
>> is to see to to reveal who actually kept
their garments
>> white and spotted. Right. Depend on the
Lord. Right.
>> Right. And and you know it's interesting
here it says that the white robe is
given to these martyrs
>> while they're dead.
>> Yeah.
>> That is a spiritual robe.
>> In other words, it's God's way of saying
don't cry out.
>> Yeah.
>> Your case is secure.
>> Absolutely.
>> You kept your garments during your life.
You're already clothed in white
spiritually,
>> he says. But now he says, um, but
there's still another group of martyrs
to be killed in the future. That's
during the little time of trouble,
correct? As we know it. Yeah.
>> There's going to be another group of
martyrs. And then when that group of
martyrs is complete, and of course yours
is complete, then I am going to reward
all of you with a white robe when I
return again.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, uh, so there's a literal and
then there's a spiritual. as well. Um,
you know, also it might be a good idea
to read Matthew 22.
>> Yes.
>> Uh, let's not read the whole passage.
Uh, but let's just read one particular
verse.
>> Absolutely. There
>> in Matthew 22.
>> Yeah. And I'll read it here. This is the
parable of the feast, the wedding feast,
right?
>> And let's remember what happened there
in that experience. Uh it says there I'm
going to read in verse
I'll say here verse 11. Yes. But when
the king came in to see the guest he saw
a man there who did not have on a
wedding garment.
>> So he said to him, "Friend, how did you
come in here without a wedding garment?"
And he was speechless. And the king said
to the servant, "Bind him hand and foot.
take him away and cast him into utter
darkness. There will be weeping and
nashing of teeth. For many are called,
but few are chosen.
>> So, so the the point of view here is
that the the gospel goes to the Jews.
>> Yes.
>> They reject it. This is in the Old
Testament. Then G uh we find Jesus
coming and uh they reject him too.
>> Yes. And so after the fatted calf is
killed,
>> then you have uh the message going to
the Gentiles.
>> Yeah.
>> And when the wedding chamber is full,
that's one that's a way of saying when
everybody has already made their
decision.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh probation closes and then uh comes
the moment to examine the guest to see
if they have the right to be in there.
>> Yeah. uh if they've kept their garments
in other words
>> and if they have not kept their garments
the judgment will show that they haven't
>> and as a result uh they'll perish when
Jesus comes. Um the important thing is
here that we have an investigative
judgment. Yes. Because
>> the wedding does not take place on
earth.
>> The wedding takes place in heaven
>> and the wedding between Christ and all
of the faithful. In other words, the
kingdom are his faithful people,
>> right?
>> And Jesus is the husband of his faithful
people. And the marriage takes place
when probation closes. Every case has
been looked at. It's been revealed who
has kept their garments white and uh and
so their case is absolutely secure. This
cannot be referring to uh events that
take place after the second coming where
somebody sneaks into heaven, right? and
uh and the king comes out to examine all
the guests and says, "How'd you make it
to heaven?" No,
>> this is an investigative judgment that
determines who is a member of Christ's
bride so that when he comes, he'll give
them a literal white garment so that
they can walk in white. And pastor, you
know, it's important to make a point
that the white garment that we
spiritually are to have is obviously the
righteousness of Jesus, but it has to
become
our experience. It has to become our our
own.
>> Um, and if you don't have that, you
won't be able to truly keep that
experience growing or or dependency on
the Lord. And and this actually what
what makes it clear in Revelation 19 uh
verse 8 where it speaks there how his
you know his bride is clothed and it
says there and to her speaking of the
bride
>> it was granted to be arrayed in fine
linen clean and bright and then it
speaks for the fine linen is the
righteous acts of the saints
>> so is it the righteousness of the saints
no of course the righteousness the
saints they don't ex they don't have
that but is righteous acts as they have
embraced Christ in their lives as they
have walked with Christ as they have you
know become one with Christ depended on
Christ their actions reflect the Lord's
actions their their deeds their behavior
is a reflection of Christ so it is it is
so important that we keep this in mind
because if you're not depending on the
Lord if you're not communing with God if
you're not having that daily walk and
and experience of Christ you can defile
you can defile your garment And unless
you return quickly, you your garments
may be removed from you or you may not
longer walk with in the light and
therefore lose uh that clothing and be
naked.
>> Yeah. You know, when we receive Christ
as our savior,
at that very moment uh Christ takes away
our filthy robes
>> which is really nakedness.
>> Yes.
>> And covers us with his righteousness.
>> With the robe of his righteousness. But
then
uh the process of sanctification begins.
>> Yes.
>> It doesn't mean once you have the robe
always you have the robe.
>> Exactly. That's
>> you can soil your garment. Now say but
what if we sin after after our baptism
after giving our lives to the Lord? Well
we have an advocate with the father
Jesus Christ the righteous.
>> Amen.
>> If we're truly sorry
>> you know not crocodile tears. If we're
truly sorry
>> then uh Jesus intercedes for us.
>> Absolutely. and brings forgiveness,
applies his blood. It's not that he
gives us a robe, he takes away the robe.
He gives us a robe, he takes away the
robe. No,
>> when we receive Jesus, he gives us a
robe
>> and then during the investigative
judgment, it is determined whether the
person kept their robe or not.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Uh so, so the life is extremely
important. Ellen White speaks of the
robes of character. Yeah. The robe
represents the character of Christ that
needs to be developed every day. We need
to have spiritual growth growth every
day.
>> Absolutely. Amen. Okay. The next
question, pastor, is from uh J Gyrie. We
don't know where he's from, and we
encourage our viewers to send not only
your name and your location, your
address, but also your location. We love
to know where you're writing us from. In
Leviticus 11:27
he asked it says all manner of beasts
that go on all four and we shall not
touch their carcasses for they are
unclean.
What about our pets like dogs and cats?
Should we not touch them when they die?
So I guess uh our friend Gyrie is asking
if he or she's has pets or you know cats
or dogs when they die should we not
touch them based on the verse of
Leviticus 11:27.
>> Well Leviticus chapter 11 uh is a list
of the animals that can be eaten and the
animals that cannot be eaten. So here
we're dealing not with living animals,
we're dealing with animals that have
died, touching animals that are dead.
Uh, you know, it's interesting. Ellen
White, uh, this is just a little tidbit.
Ellen White, uh, had a dog called
Tiglath Pelzer. Uh, now Tiglas Pelizer
was a desperate. He was a very cruel
Assyrian ruler. And the reason why she
called that dog that way is because it
was a watchdog. And she said it is a
terror to evildoers.
And of course uh she lived in Sunnyside
in Australia at that time.
>> So uh you know there's nothing wrong
with hugging your dog and petting your
dog and playing with your dog uh which
is an unclean animal.
>> Um but this is referring to a dead
animal.
>> And uh you know you're dealing with
cultic prescriptions here. You're
dealing God is trying to teach Israel
that there's a distinction between clean
and unclean, right? between good and
evil, between right and wrong. And God
is trying to find vehicles whereby he
can uh establish that distinction
>> between what is clean and what is
unclean.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, you take for example native
God said take holy fire,
>> there's holy fire and the fire used to
cook with.
>> Yeah.
>> He's trying to establish that there's a
difference
>> between one and the other. God is
binary.
>> Mhm.
>> You know, for God there's no gray areas.
>> Amen for that. there's either clean or
unclean and that's the lesson that God
wants to teach. But over and above that
>> um uh I found this on the internet
beyond religious interpretations
there are also practical health reasons
for avoiding contact with dead animals
>> not living animals dead animals.
Carcasses can harbor bacteria
>> and viruses that can be harmful to
humans and pets.
>> Diseases like tarmia
which can be spread through contact with
infected mammals are a potential risk.
Therefore, even in the absence of
religious rules,
>> it is generally advisable to avoid
touching dead animals to prevent
potential illness.
>> Correct. Uh so like you need to remain
separate from moral evil, moral
uncleanness.
>> It's actually quite a good idea to
become separate from what potentially
could cause you physical damage.
>> Absolutely. And so it is important to
keep in mind that when you have an
animal even if it's a clean animal or in
the case a pet or something like that
that has you know has died you are to be
very mindful not to uh you know keep it
I don't know uh looking at it you know
he he's dead you know bury it uh take a
shovel take take care of it bury it
don't leave it you know laying around uh
try to just for prevention, you should
probably put gloves and just, you know,
put it on on this place. It's just it's
just a good habit to do to avoid any
potential harm or any potential disease
by touching dead animals. And again, it
could be either one, you know, clean or
unclean. But uh thank you for that. And
I think this will help uh Jerai uh know
how to properly dispose of an animal
that has died. Uh we have probably
uh
>> one more thing if you might mention.
Yeah, Buster.
>> Uh, the context is not dealing with your
pets,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> The context is in in the case of the
animals that are killed to be eaten. And
God says, "Don't eat dead. Don't eat
animals that are unclean."
>> And he he's not talking about your pet
that died.
>> He's talking about animals that were
killed with the purpose of eating.
>> Right. Right. Right. It's important to
keep that in mind. Thank you, pastor.
So, we have perhaps time for a short
question here. we have and uh it's again
Jur Jira askked us this question is
there a specific way of a wedding
ceremony that is in the Bible because a
common wedding ceremony we see like
wearing a white gown and veils and rings
is a pagan ceremony
um well this is an interesting thought
the the guen ceremony some of these
practices have come throughout the
centuries and many of them are indeed in
pagan cultures but not every single
aspect of them are necessarily pagan in
itself. You know why why why is a woman
dressed in white is a symbol of purity
being a virgin. Uh so that's not actual
as a matter of fact that's a biblical
application. We have the evidence in the
Bible you know in the revelation about
the you know clothe in white woman. It
also says in verse two of Revelation 21,
"Then I, John, saw the holy city, New
Jerusalem, coming down out of heaven
from God, prepared as a bride adorned
for her husband."
>> Yeah.
>> Which is interesting.
>> Exactly. So we have these things that
are in the Bible but and certainly there
are some aspects of a wedding ceremony
today that are probably found in pagan
cultures but uh the Bible has given us
uh evidence that it's a process the Lord
rejoices in and as long as we don't go
against biblical principles I think the
practices or the customs are not
necessarily defined because it's a at
the end it's an experience of two
individuals meeting to become one. I
think more of an issue is how much you
spend on your wedding.
>> Absolutely.
>> Your stewardship.
>> Exactly.
>> Because sometimes people go terribly
overboard in the expense of the wedding.
>> And so we need to exercise good
stewardship and modesty. There's whole a
whole group of principles that we need
to apply when we talk about marriage.
>> Absolutely. Well, we look uh forward to
hearing your from you again from your
questions. We thank you for allowing us
to come to you and please don't forget
to pray for us and we thank you for your
contribution, your support that allows
us to continue making these programs for
you. May God bless you.
[Music]